abone ol
ilk öncelikle teşekkür ederim bu mahçup
edecek konuşma içinde Emeği geçen
herkese teşekkürler değerli konuklarla
beraber burada olduğu için ben çok
mutluyum En çok da sizlere teşekkür
ederim Buraya kadar yoğurduk sizi Hoş
geldiniz tekrar sağlığım abi aslında ben
bugün başımdan geçen bazı olayları
bildiğin bazı olaylarla Bildiğim bazı bu
Bu dinamiklerle size Anlatmaya
çalışacağım konumuz daha çok bildiğiniz
üzere Şener rasyonlar nesiller arası ya
da insanlar arası iletişim anlamak
anlaşılmak ya da anlaşılamamak Bak ilk
anlatacağım
bu hikayenin başrolü benim Adana'da
geçiyor olay ılık Bir Bahar Akşamı ki
Adana'da Bahar akşamlar Çok güzel
deminki Burada da öyledir bir
konservatuvara girdim ilk Yılın son
zamanlarıydı son aylarıydı konservatuara
daha önceki Deniz etrafından geçiniz
duyanınız bileniniz varsa konservatuar
binasına girersiniz her odadan farklı
bir ses gelir farklı enstrüman sesleri
geliyor sonra siz onca ses arasından
öyle bir sesin cazibesine kapılırsınız
cezbeder size ceddine kapılırsınız
cezbeder ve o sese doğru gidersiniz
derste Acaba nereden geliyorsa sıkıntı
oluyor bu şarkıyı diye Ben de o sese
Kapıldım gittim be yanılmadım çok
sevdiğim hocam Çok da Hayran Olduğum
hocam bilmiyorum sizden hayranlık
beğendiğim çocukluk aşkı öbür desen
imkansız bilmiyorum her neyse gittim
şarkı çalıyor ben de sessizce Odaya
girdim dinledim
bir şey açıkmı çıkarmadım şarkının
sonuna kadar Şarkı bitti benim gözlerim
dolmuştu sanıyorum
bu ne soracağım da anlamıştı hocam
Beğendin mi de çok beğendim dedim Ne
dedim bu şarkı benim şarkıları benim
beslen dedi ne anlatıyorsunuz dedim asla
sordum anda biraz saçma bir şey
sorduğumda farkındaydım Ama kendime
engel olamadım istersen anlatayım dedi
sana baştan aşağı baştan sona anlatayım
da hepsini olur bile diyemedim başımı
salladım O da şarkıyı baştan sona tekrar
çaldı Aslında kısmen cevabını cevabını
cevabını alıştım ben durumu iç sesimi
çıkarmadım Ama olayın farkına varmam
yaklaşık yirmi yılımı aldı 20 yıl sonra
Bir kitapta okumuştum ona benzer bir
şeyi
bu şarkıdaki gibi ve o anda tekrar 20
yıl öncesine döndüm ne anlatmaya
çalıştım daha iyi anladım Yani neden
Aslında sözcüklerin çok yetersiz
olduğunu Bunu neden elimizdeki sözcük
sayısıyla o Aklımızdan geçen ya da
Aklımızın tavanı olmadığı durumlarda
içinizden geçen duyguları Neden
anlatamadığımız Çünkü genellikle
sözcükler ve duygular birbirini tutmuyor
sözcüklere duyguların deliğine hızına ya
da üstünü yetişemiyor lar zaten o yüzden
işte müzik var resim var tiyatro var
sanat Var mı başka şeyler de var eşyalar
var jestler ve mimikler var vücut dili
var ve ki sözcüklerin çok daha ötesinde
çok önemli durumlar var yapılması
gereken anlatmak için yani bu şuna
benziyor İlla Seni seviyorum demenize
gerek yoktur elinizden geliyorsa bir şey
yazarsınız şarkı söyle
bu olmadı mı Heavy Kırmızıgül alırsınız
O da olmadı bir yemeğe götürürsün bir
şeyler yaparsanız yani Ama bunu ifade
etmenin bundan çok daha derin en az 40
tane çeşidi var bir Demek ki doğru
sözcüğü seçmek yerine belki de o sözlü
ifade eden doğru durumu seçmek ya da
doğru durumu ortaya Kiko evime çok daha
önemli ile şimdi ve bu bu zaman zaman
çok zor bir durum Hem nesiller arası ki
fark açıldıkça doğru sözcüğü bulma biraz
daha da zorlaşıyor Acaba hangi doğru söz
Yani ben bir sözcük kullanıyorum acaba
karşıdaki bunu almıyor vereyim birinin
korkudan anladı şey Yalnızlık oluyor
öbürünün Korkut anladı şey mesela
internet bağlantısının olmaması oluyor
Ve çok örnek var Farklı farklı çok örnek
var ve demek ki
bu doğru sözcüğü seçilmek çok önemli
bununla beraber Bence özellikle
yaşadığımız Dönemin en büyük
sorunlarından bir tanesi dinleme Daha
doğrusu Belki de dinleyememe ya da
dinlemeyi bilemem
bu çünkü bakmak ve görmek ne kadar Ayrı
Dünyalar sa
bu dinlemek ve duymak o kadar başka
dünyalar bir duyuyoruz genellikle ama
dinlemeye bilmiyoruz eğitimde çok önem
verilmedi buna evet yıllardır yani de
diksiyon güzel yazı sunum teknikleri bir
sürü ders abi ama çok azdır rastlanan
dinleme Yani nasıl iyi dinleyici olur
çünkü olmazsa ki sözüm meclisten dışarı
bazı televizyon programlarına bunu sık
sık tarafta her gün görüyoruz dinlemeye
beceremeyen dinleme özürlü bir nesil
yetişiyor yetişti ve bu bir döngü Eğer
çözülmezse bu konu bu problem beceremez
s
Bu bir sorun olarak kalmaya devam edecek
bu ve iletişimin en az 150 kısımdan
bahsediyoruz ve ne olacak dinlemeye
Başladığım zaman daha iyi bir baba daha
iyi bir arkadaş daha iyi bir eş ve daha
iyi bir insan olacağız
Ama şöyle bir şey sorsam bir problemin
Bu ilk adımı nedir Yani o problemi
çözmenin ilk adımı nedir sizce
iyi anlamak bak Ama anlamak çözmeye
yeter mi Bülent Ortaçgil de söylemiştim
değil mi anlamak çözmeye yetmez sensiz
olmaz Hatta durum Anlaşılamadı ki Müslüm
Gürses tekrar Üzerine basa basa söyledi
bunu tekrar anlamak çözmeye yetmez Evet
anlamak için üzerinde düşünmek lazım
dinlemek lazım web
ve dinleyen insanlar oldu anlayamayan
duymayan başka bir olaydan bahsedeyim
bu okullarda zaman zaman tanıtım günleri
olur her gün bölümden bir hocaya o
bölümde durur sonra çocuklar gelir
anneleriyle babalarıyla da yalnız meslek
hakkında gelecekler hakkında mesleğin
geleceği hakkında bilgiler aldılar bir
unutmuyorum o gün ben bulunuyordum orada
bir Babayla kız geldi yanıma böyle kız
biraz çekingen ürkek baba da son derece
kararlı bir ve direk Baba konuya dağıldı
şöyle
Evet hocam dedi gözün sevmiştim bir şey
söyle artık olacağım dedi Nasıl dedim
artık
var ya tiyatro olacakmış yatırmaya
bilmem ne falan hocam gözün sen de şunu
yola getir falan filan dedi tam da
adamda söyledi duymak istemezdim böyle
birşey kız yani böyle çok üzgün açık
gözlerle bana bakıyordu babası son
derece kararlı dedim Ne güzel yani ne
kadar zor ve güzel bir yol seçmiş ne
kadar önemli bir şey gönül vermiş Neden
dedim yani ne var bunda dedim anlattı
bir sürü şey ve anlattıklarından tabi
işte içinde doğduğu kültür geçmişte
bilmem ne yanlış izlenimler ve sürü şey
anlattı falan bekledim
Sen neredesin Yüzyıl önce birisi şöyle
bir laf etmiş Duydunuz mu dedim Ne demiş
dedi herkes milletvekili olabilir
belediye başkanı olabilir Başbakan olur
hatta cumhurbaşkanı bir olur ama Herkes
sanatçı olamaz burada Duygu dedi
duymadım kim söylemiş dedi atatürkler de
Sağ ol canım Sonra bir şey söylemeden
kız Teşekkür ederim gözlerle bana
bakıyordu sonra gittiler ne oldu
bilmiyorum ama herhalde adam cevabını
almıştı ve bu örneği Samsun'da yani
Kurtuluş Savaşı'mızın başladığı yerde
tekrar anlatabilmek ve Atatürk'ü anmak
çok güzel bir resimli Peki ne yapacağız
Bu bir şey istemek sadece sözel olarak
ifade etmeye uygun olmayabiliyor mesela
ben bir örnek vereyim
abone ol
bu Kemal çalıyordum sonra gitara Gönül
Verdim ailemden Bana gitar almalarını
istiyorum ama istemek etmeyecektin yani
Bana gitar alır mısınız Demek ki hafif
kalacaktı Ben de ilk şaka yaptım gitarla
arkadaşlar Gitar aldım üç İlk şarkım
yaptım sonra ertesi doğum gününde hemen
bana bir gitar aldılar sağolsunlar Şimdi
bazı şeylere gel okul içinde belki Hani
tiyatroda olmak istiyorum demek çözüm
değil Belki onu göstermesi lazım başka
bir şeylerle yani o Arzu'yu tutkuyu
başka bir dille ifade etmesi lazım belki
babası ancak öyle anlayacakta bunu başka
boyutu da var o da asla beğendiğiniz
alakalı beğendiğimiz ve Bizi biz yapan
değerler benliğimizin hızlı pencereleri
gizli kapılarımız belki karanlık
yönlerimiz ve sanıyorum ki bu alanlar
aydınlandı cça insan kendini daha iyi
tanıyacak ve itibariyle
ve başkalarını da daha iyi tanıyacak
empati kuracak başkalarının denizden de
anlıyor olacak sanıyorum günümüzdeki en
büyük sorunlardan biri bu anlamak
anlaşamamak yani konuşmak ve sözler
yetmiyor görüyoruz bunu sık sık
görüyoruz her yerde herkese hoşuna
görüyoruz Ben Bazen derslerde böyle 8-10
tane öğrenci kaldırıyorum diyorum ki
kendinizi bize 5 kelimeyle Yani beş
durumu anlattım başlıyorlar işte
bu düşen geç Çalışkan sabırsız bilmem
böyle böyle gidiyor böyle Tamam peki
Evet şimdi bunda bir sorun yok ve
bahsettikleri şeyler geneli zaten
onların da bildiği herkese Milliye
durumlar ki Normaldir yani Kimse kendine
vermek istemez üzüm kartları açmak
istemez bunlardan bahsediyorlar ama asla
sonra burada başlama iletişim dibi ve bu
jenerasyonlar arasında çok sık yaşanıyor
çünkü başka bölgelerimizde var bizim
yani Benden Öte Benden Ziyade Barış
Manço dediğim gibi gerçek var ortada
Peki ne neden bahsediyoruz bunların
bazıları enteresan bazıları korkunç
bazlar acıkla mesela bazı durumlar var
kilitli ya da gizli bir bölgemiz var
açık bölgemiz var kapalı bölgemiz var
bilinmeyen bölgemiz var bazı durumlar
var insanlardan gizlemeye çalışıyoruz
korkularımız normaldir çekince lerimiz
hasretliğimiz gizliyoruz insanlardan
bunları gayet normal anlaşılabilir bunu
da problem görmüyorum
bu alanlar var ki sanıyorum en acıklı
sıra bu Siz farkında değilsiniz Ama
herkes farkında Bu çok acıklı yani
Mesela Siz çok romantik olduğunu
zannediyorsunuz ama uzunsunuz ya da o
cinsten bir şey söylemiştir ya da mesela
Çok esprili olduğunu sanıyorsunuz ama
Fıkrasına Gülünmeyen Adam Sizsiniz yada
buna benzer birçok örnek yani Komik
Olmayan komedinin Ovacıklı durumu gibi
işte bunları aydınlatmak gerekiyor
Kendini daha iyi anlamak gerekiyor Bir
de başka bir yolu daha var ki zaman
zaman bu en tehlikelisi zaman zamanda
mucizevi arada İşte o bilinmeyen Siz
çünkü
o deri nerede olan durumun nesi
farkındasınız ne de başkaları sadece
hayata geçirmesi geçirilmesi için uygun
zamanı kolluyor bu duygularınız bu
beğendiğiniz ve bazen bir durum oluyor
Mucizeler yatırıyorsunuz bazen bir durum
oluyor her şeyi berbat edebiliyorsunuz
yani içinden bir canavar çıkabiliyor ya
da bir sanatçı çıkabiliyor Ama kimse
bunu bilmiyor ta ki şartlar olduğu
yaşına kadar soğuk kızıma kadar ya da o
doğru an gelene kadar ama burada önemli
olan sanıyorum
o karanlık Daha doğrusu bilinmeyen Siz
bilinmeyen alanlarınız sizi yakalamadan
O sizin onları keşfetmeniz sizin Onlar
yakalamamız lazım ve
var bunun içinde bazı şeyler yapmak
gerek
ve kendinizi araştırmak anlamak
tecrübelerinizden faydalanmak
tecrübelerini gözden geçirmek içinde
doğduğumuz kültürü anlamak Empati yapmak
ve bunları yaptıkça Bunlar uyguladık
Çaki biliyorsunuz hiç eğitimden sonra
bu Mucizeler hemen gerçekleşmez o
anlatılanları uygulaya bildiğimiz
noktada değişim başlar ve
ve iletişimde de çok önemlidir
bir insan değiştikçe baktığı her şey
değişir ve dokunduğu her şeyde değişir
değişir zaten kaçınılmaz O yüzden çok
ince bir çizgideyiz anlamak ve
anlaşılmak Ama önce bence okuduklarımdan
gördüklerimden duyduklarımdan
ama anladığım kadarıyla
bu anlaşmaya ve anlatmaya ya İnsan
kendinden başlamalı kendimizi anlayarak
yani kendinizi anlarsak bilirsek
sanıyorum başkalarını anlayacağız
derdinizi anlatabileceğiniz ya daha
mutlu daha iyi bir insan olacağız ve
sanıyorum günümüzde bu çok büyük bir
eksiklik ve aşılması gereken önemli bir
sorun olarak karşımıza çıkıyor benim
anlatacaklarım bu kadardı sizlere beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
sağolun İyi ki geldiniz iyiki varsın